Traductor: Inés Aniorte Díaz
Revisor: Jenny Lam-Chowdhury
Los tatuajes siempre
se presentan en los medios
como marcas peligrosas y pervertidas
o moda pasajera de la juventud.
Pero, mientras que
los estilos de tatuaje vienen y van
y su significado cambia mucho
según la cultura,
su práctica es tan antigua
como la civilización misma.
En restos humanos
del mundo entero,
se han visto marcas decorativas
y la más antigua se encontró
en la piel de una momia peruana
del año 6000 a.C.
¿Pero se han preguntado
cómo funcionan realmente los tatuajes?
Nuestra piel muda
y pierde cada hora
de 30 a 40 mil células,
es decir, como 1 millón diarias.
Entonces, ¿por qué el tatuaje
no se desconcha gradualmente con ellas?
La respuesta es sencilla.
El pigmento del tatuaje es más profundo
que la capa más externa.
A lo largo de la historia,
diversas culturas
han usado varios métodos.
Pero la primera máquina moderna
de tatuar se diseñó
tras la máquina de grabar
de Thomas Edison y era eléctrico.
Las máquinas de tatuar
de hoy en día
insertan agujas finas
con tinta en la piel
a una velocidad de
50 a 3000 veces por minuto.
Las agujas perforan la epidermis
y la tinta se inyecta incluso
más profundo, en la dermis,
donde hay fibras de colágeno, nervios,
glándulas, vasos sanguíneos y demás.
Cada vez que la aguja penetra,
hace una herida
que alerta al cuerpo
para que comience
el proceso inflamatorio
y llame a las células inmunitarias
para que reparen la piel.
Este proceso es lo que
los hace permanentes.
Primero, los macrófagos,
células especializadas,
se comen el material invasor
para limpiar la inflamación.
Cuando las células pasan
por el sistema linfático,
algunas llevan la panza llena de tinta
en los ganglios linfáticos
y otros yacen en la dermis.
Como no pueden
deshacerse del pigmento
la tinta puede verse
a través de la piel.
Algunas partículas quedan
en la matriz de gel de la dermis
mientras las células cutáneas
o fibroblastos se comen otras.
Al principio, la tinta
se deposita en la epidermis
pero a medida que la piel se cura
se van las células dañadas
y otras nuevas
sin tinta las sustituyen,
y la primera capa se despelleja
como cuando uno se quema con el sol.
No suelen verse ampollas o cicatrices
en los tatuajes profesionales
y en 2-4 semanas
se regenera la piel.
No se debe tomar el sol
o nadar durante este tiempo
para que no desaparezca.
Pero las células cutáneas
permanecen en su lugar hasta morir.
Luego las jóvenes las sustituyen
así la tinta se queda.
Pero con el tiempo los tatuajes
desaparecen naturalmente,
a medida que el cuerpo reacciona
a las partículas de pigmentos,
que son destruidas lentamente
y transportadas por los macrófagos
del sistema inmunitario.
La radiación ultravioleta
puede hacer desaparecer el pigmento,
aunque se puede reducir
con protector solar.
Como las células cutáneas son estables,
mucha tinta permanece
dentro de la piel para siempre.
Pero si están para siempre,
¿los puedo borrar?
Técnicamente sí.
Hoy en día, se usa un láser
que entra en la epidermis
y destruye los pigmentos por debajo.
El color más fácil
de borrar es el negro.
El láser rompe
los glóbulos de tinta
en partículas pequeñas
que los macrófagos eliminan.
Hay otros colores
más difíciles de quitar
y puede complicarse.
Por eso borrar un tatuaje
es más difícil que ponérselo,
pero no imposible.
Quizás un tatuaje
no dure para siempre,
pero los tatuajes han sobrevivido
más que cualquier cultura.
Y su popularidad hace pensar
que llegó para quedarse.